my son i asked him recently here hey man  so you got any um  any stories i don't know about i'm  looking for some new jokes  and he said  i won't get in trouble  i don't know you man you're not going to  get trouble he goes okay oh okay  okay oh okay oh okay uh  oh did i ever tell you that time when  you and mom were out of town  and i had some friends over and we all  did acid i said [ __ ] no  and he goes do you want to hear about  that time i go yeah that's the exact  time i do want to hear about  and he goes okay okay all i'm going to  tell you is this  when i woke up the next morning  the pizza guy was still here  [Applause]  that means that dude walked into the  party was like hey [ __ ] this a dollar an  hour job  i'll find another one of these tomorrow  i'm getting [ __ ] up tonight  [Music]  you